[Music]  Carrie Underwood solidifies the CMT  Awards record with her 18th win whoever  went and voted for anybody just thank  you for taking the time Thank You  Ludacris for wanting to inspire the 35  year old singer proved she's still the  queen of country music during Wednesday  night's CMT Awards in Nashville  Tennessee though Kerry was nominated for  four awards and only took home one for  female video of the year with her song  at the champion featuring rapper  Ludacris she still holds the record for  the most CMT Awards ever one  [Music]  [Applause]  before her win Kerry blew the audience  away with a powerful performance of her  new hit single cry pretty while her  husband Mike Fisher was seen watching  and clapping along in the audience  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]